[Music]
let's continue with Community member
extraordinaire and back-end engineer at
Spotify Muhammad abelite showing us how
to build a fast workflow with kubernetes
and Java welcome Muhammad
hello everyone
I am Muhammad I was a I work as a
back-end engineer at Spotify and also
I'm Cloud Google Cloud innovator
champion and today I'm going to
highlight some great open source
projects by Google Cloud team thank you
for that that makes working with Java
and kubernetes especially GK a lot more
fun and speed up our development
workflow
so when we talk about
when we talk about developer workflow
and some We call we call it also the
inner development workflow we talk about
four major steps the first one in is
introducing business changes making new
feature introducing new feature fixing a
bug or actually just improving the user
experience right we call that the code
uh phase and then once we are happy with
our changes we compile the code we build
it in order to generate an artifact that
could be in a traditional Java
application a jar or air whatever Java
artifacts you have or you can build
actually that container image
once we build our artifact we deploy it
either to a traditional Java application
server or it could be to the cloud in a
kubernetes or whatever your container
orchestration tool and finally we do
some primitive testing now I'm not
talking about integration test unit
tests I'm just talking you opening the
browser or whatever API tool you want to
have and testing actually your changes
so this is actually the four major
phases of our development workflow right
however when move it to Containers into
the cloud containers are great right
they become the executables of the cloud
and they change the way we develop
architecture and deploy our containers
they have a lot of goodness we heard for
the past 10 years a lot of goodness
about containers a lot of companies
breaching how how some they are right
however when it comes to development
they didn't make actually the
development experience fun they bring
this additional layer of abstraction
that made the developer experience a
little bit a little bit slow now let's
take this example
those are the steps that are typical a
developer will follow in order to deploy
its changes like we start with building
our Java artifact then uh building our
image using Docker build common right
then we tag that push it God I'm getting
I'm not even halfway through I'm tired
and then we change our manifest uh
deploy it using Cube uh Cube Cube CTR
apply we connect to our cluster check if
the ports are healthy check in the locks
and finally checking up testing our
changes ah I made it
so if we want to
decompose and categorize those all steps
we can categorize them into four five
major categories actually the first one
is the belt so we built our artifact and
generate our uh
container jar whatever and then we'll
continue sorry here we in the
controllers phase we generate our
container image and there we we push it
to our remote registry
and then we deploy it in our favorite
container orchestration tool and then we
connect to that cluster to check if
everything is working right however we
as developers we don't care about all
the steps right we only care about
introducing changes making changes and
checking that the code we wrote Works
according to expectation it does the job
that we need to do and
in 2014 a dear friend which is James
Ward which is La cotton PM wrote that
long development and validation Cycles
really sucks
so when a developer spent a lot of time
waiting for the changes waiting to see
and test their changes actually their
productivity will act eventually plunge
and it will affect the business because
a slow developer means that the whole
team would be slow to deliver a feature
and it will also mean that the other
teams that depend on your team will
actually get slow so the whole business
becomes you get slower losing billions
of dollars just for fast of a broken
developer experience if I might say
so this has nothing to do with my
presentation I'm just like trying to
look Smart in front of a smart audience
but that's only to say that uh we need
to analyze the five steps and try if we
can automate them optimize them in order
to make the developer experience working
with containers and in this case Java
and some of the tools apply to other
languages but I'll be focusing on Java
in this case
and
analyzing the two first steps which is
the build and continue rise there are
some issues and some
um
things that we can improve uh regarding
uh the way we build our containers
images right
starting with the builds take longer
when we build our container our
artifacts and containers compared to
when we build them locally with our
favorite build tools like Maven or
Gradle right whatever we do whatever we
optimize the building containers take
longer compared to building our Java
artifact directly
with the rise to of cloud native and to
move to Fat jars by all the Java
Frameworks springboard micronauts
quarkers we started building the fat
jars now fat jars are great if you're
running them directly however they break
the caching optimizations of Docker and
containers in general since each time
you change a tiny little bit of your
code you are building a new fat jar and
that means and you hash ID of your image
layer and that needs a slow push process
and slow pull and deploy process as well
there are some limitations with the
docker belt comment like sequential
execution it cannot execute comments in
parallel there are some caching issues
and especially if you are mounting
folders there are some it will use your
current file system with root files no
caching issues for security reasons
obviously
and uh no volume sorry and finally there
are no safe way to access in uh private
repositories such as get or history now
to be completely transparent here those
issues are some of them are solved with
buildkit so if you are not using build
kit yet try to enable it in your Docker
desktop
and finally Docker CLI is great is it
has a lot of options to enable you to do
magic things however it's become
overloaded over the year with more
features that are necessarily developed
or focused it has features for Docker
swarm always using Docker smart whatever
and a couple of years back it has like
some features for Docker ee right so
it's maybe not the right tool for the
job
and we as Java developers are familiar
with the standardized artifact like we
are familiar with building our code and
generating a jar a war and air whatever
and the ideal scenario for us would be
to use the same old build tools Maven
and Gradle and generate the new unit of
deployment of the cloud which is
containers and thanks to the Google
Cloud Engineers we have such tool it's
called Google Jet and it stands for Java
image Builder
so Java image Builder is actually a pure
Java plugin so if you want to improve
something fix something you can actually
just contribute to the code is open
source it uses both Maven and Gradle and
my favorite part is actually it's
demoless meaning that you don't need to
have a Docker this demon and solid on
your machine and it is fast especially
under producible builds and it's
reproducible and what jib does is
basically similar to what's in this
Docker file so jib since it's a Java
plugin it splits your application into
multiple layers so it benefits from the
caching mechanism of containers and you
put the files that are less likely to
change on the top which are the your
dependencies your resources and the
files are more likely to change on the
bottom which are our class files and
that helps if you change it only the
class files only one layer will get
changed rather than the whole uh
application basically so that's why the
reason why it's fast especially in the
reproducible bits
and
jip is really customizable really
configurable you can configure anything
you want your base image
um it I forgot to mention that it
generates oci compatible formats so
that's why you don't need to have a
Docker demon it has three major faces or
three major goals the first one is J
belt or Maven J Bell if you want to it
basically Builds an image and push it to
a remote registry
if you want to Cache your image locally
in your Docker demon you can use Docker
build and if you generate a tarp a chart
file then you can do that with buildtar
and the default base image in jib it
uses destroys Java and this is Java is a
part of a Google cool Google Cloud
projects as well called a destroys
container images now the Solace
container images aims to create
Contender images that are contains only
your application and its runtime
dependencies restricting what's inside
your application or your container to
exactly what your application needs to
perform its function
now that is great for two reasons from a
security point of view since you have
only what you need during runtime and
from a size point of view which means
that you will have faster push and you
will have have faster pull and deploy as
well
and so with jib we hopefully managed to
reduce the build and continuous time
how about deployment time can we
automate the other steps which is like
tagging our images pushing it and
deploying it to our cluster and another
cool open source projects from the
Google Cloud Engineers called scaffold
super easy it's basically a command line
tool it's a common CLI that does a lot
of things it reminds the build of your
container pushing it deploying it and
entertaining the logs and even does a
port forwarding if you want to have that
now you can use scaffold on the favorite
CI tool and save it into your favorite
style side tool so you have a consistent
experience between the development and
CI CD but we're gonna focus on the
development uh part in this talk
so this is what basic was scaffold
basically does does a lot of things it
sync the files it's uh build your
control the container image for you it
tag it different different tagging
strategies it tests it and here you can
either use another cool project open
source container structure tests that
enable you to test the structure of your
container image and verify its
compliance or you can Define your Custom
Custom text similar to what we do with
Maven tests or gradual tests or whatever
and it enables you to tag your artifacts
and then generate the Manifest
so if you are using customize or hell it
helps to generate the final manifest
before deploying them and then once you
deployed it tail the logs and gather
them giving you a great overview of how
your application is doing so you can
have a quick feedback loop and for and
with that I'm going to demo some of
scaffold and jib uh features so before
going here I have first a very small
spring boot application that is
basically have one endpoint
which is a Hello uh application that
whenever is it visible in the back
cool so it's a basically one endpoint
that Sprints an event stream so it's one
second and it says hello words
so I have scaffold already configured
and I have the configuration file here
so as everything in Cloud native word
it's a yaml file you need to live with
it and I Define it multiple steps
so the first one is the build step and
I'm basically using jip and as you can
see in my pump file I have the jib
plugin already here the latest version I
hope
and then for the test I'm using the
structured tests
um so as I mentioned you can use the
structure test which is another cool
project from the Google Cloud team and
it's basically verified the structure
and the compliance of your application
so here I'm verifying the Java version
of my container that is Java 17. the
user ID and I'm checking that the layers
the files that jeep creates are there
already so quick win
I'm also doing some port forwarding from
8080 the default Port of springboot to
Port 900 and deploying using Cube CDL
and if I want to start scaffold I'm only
have to in develop in development mode I
have to do scaffold Dev and what it
basically does it will start to get if I
have the image locally it would start to
put it up otherwise it will build a new
one
push it to the container image and
deploy it using Cube CDL as I've
mentioned it here and it will try to
pull the logs and deploy the application
now this is taking more time than
expected
uh but it's uh it's getting there so
it's running to tests and the tests are
failing aha
the why do we need to do the docker
demon gosh this is not good
I need to log in okay open docker
Docker trying to uh Kill My Demo
thanks docker
let's try now
okay just run in yes all passed perfect
fantastic now I'm trying to deploy my
image
deployment is already done and you can
see here it's already Port forwarded to
post 9000 and if I'm lucky you can see
the hello world application up and
running right and now what happened if I
want to introduce some changes and
so this year I want to Google Cloud next
the moment I would next the moment I hit
Ctrl save you would see here that it
will redo the same process without me
doing anything it will try to
build a new image run the chest to make
sure that everything is fine and then
deploy it
and when port forward and then I will
see my application in the logs that my
application is started now if I go back
and refresh
I would get the Google Cloud Nest
application up and running and once I
hit Ctrl C to exit my scaffold Dev mode
you will see that the application it
will basically try to clean up your
remote cluster removing all kubernetes
objects there now this is a very simple
simple application and you may see that
you may say that yeah our production
application are more complex than that
so I have I sealed another production
similar application which is a bit store
so it's using uh
it's using actually uh necronaut and
they have it deployed in gke cluster
already so it has a micro service
application with a couple of uh with a
couple of databases so it had multiple
applications a front-end application
using react and it's all automated using
a scaffold so I have the front-end
application using react using the sync
file I'm going to demo that in a minute
and I have other application that's
using micronauts framework both within
in groovy and Java and different other
Java languages
so uh I cheated a little bit so
application is already up and running
and if I am lucky I would see that the
application is up yes so this is my
application
and I mentioned the syncing feature of
uh
scaffold right so I have the home.js
application which is the front
um the front end or the home page of my
custom application what happen if
I changed it a bit
next though the moment I hit Ctrl save I
don't no longer need to build an
application since since it's a react
application it's basically sync defies
directly to my remote cluster without
building the image as it's mentioned uh
sorry not this one probably uh it's this
one yes sync in my application so if I
go back to my application says I'm
activating the hot reload mode in my
react application it instantly picked
actually my application without needing
me to do anything
um
so
this was a quick demo of scaffold uh
goodness
so we managed to
shorten the steps from five to one maybe
or two you need to do some configuration
with Jep if you're a Java developer uh
and basically running scaffold Dev in
your uh config in your application to
have a decent and a more uh enjoyable
developer experience
upon this during the demo yaml files
uh I have a problem with the ammos but
I'm not going to start the discussion
now but yeah my files especially if
you're working in the cloud native world
are really we end up managing a lot of
yaml files per environment per version
it adds a lot of complexity
so we need a way to customize it and
you're probably already doing that
and either we have basically a couple of
options either we start using help and
Helm follows a configuration over values
kind of uh kind of solution and so you
have basically uh the base or the
configuration you define variables in
your uh kubernetes manifest and you
define the values of those of those
variables depending on the on the
version and also the environment that
you want to run your application uh into
Helm three solve it a lot of problems
and a lot of pins with hell since it
becomes now a client focused uh version
previously it was a client server and
you need to have taller or whatever is
called on your kubernetes cluster now
it's much more lightweight and it does
all its magic in the client side
and my favorite tool is actually
customize so customize as the name uh
suggests is basically a solution to
customize your application and it will
lower different approach it's basically
enable you to defer to define a skeleton
which is the shared manifest of all your
versions and all your environments
and we Define additional yamas per per
environments on per version right and
what it does is basically what's in this
slide so we Define our skeleton our base
image our base configuration file and we
Define the changes and updates that we
want to do and the generated version
will be basically the merge of those two
and we end up with a much structured
yaml file that enable us to basically
Define and deploy your application per
version and per environment
so this is basically it uh scaffold is a
great tool that we customizable and
extendable with different uh
environments for building you could use
jib you could use Docker build you could
use build packs whatever you want uh
there's different testing strategies
different tagging strategies and
different way to deploy your
applications and if you want you can
make your own uh and build your own as
well and shove it into scaffold so with
that I want to thank you and the demo of
today is already on GitHub open source
and you have any question be happy to
take them
[Applause]
thank you